very reluctant to take it but he made it
pray from just inside last two days for
personal reasons and you hoped his
conditioning is going to be solid and
he's excited to play lob up top hooker
280 men it quits lamb gets us dirty this
past year trying to get out of there but
nice pass by Devin Booker knees ascent
beautiful Venus opponent US sir Gilbert
there is a kind of a story as Colin hits
his first shot racing the rookie Jackson
Jackson Bagley for your Sacramento Kings
Herman Bagley has the bags he jumps up
and says give me that shot takes it and
gets out on his horse drop it into the
post
nice little left hand jump hook in the
pace look at this grant hurts my knees
demon wash thought about a long three
drives from
[Applause]
now with Terrence Ross let that one go
you thought that was a bad pass
unreachable oh my goodness look at Obama
go up and get that one Wow this is part
of a returns Knox 63 that drives goes
right inside drops uphold the prayers in
stiff hair for mops Grizzlies have it
first off the jump dressed in white this
afternoon
jaren Jackson off the feed from Pine
Lake now the feed has to pick up sexy
dribble drives his always froze him and
scores permit cement boots right but
nobody came to help the big fella
pump fake that driving mister thought a
good challenge by Justin holiday there
Thomas how can he fight now lay off the
ball a little more give the ball up when
the traps are coming you know they're
coming but you see when he gets all the
way to the back go back
with a more capable match here boss
bored again against Johnson just a nice
soft touch by a an innately
they'll jump up right there team
[Music]
how about the big hammer down Thank You
Grayson Allen come on man
let him show me up
was able to get him and his friend
tickets to come to the game tonight as
you looked at Jackson what a relief it
is for him to just be in some sense of
normalcy we're so happy to have him here
tonight facing up against Simmons wants
to clear it out Isaac comes with
double-team help with the shot clock
under three Ingram is gonna make a great
move splitting the defense becomes Bhama
from the weak side the Hayward does and
then bench already with 16 points
we started stored ATP as Knox cadets
cheer ejections junior off the set up
from Conley and just another beautiful
play quick screen the role here now you
attack the rim no boba defense not quite
as potent as it was a years
very ileus over and that was a big big
loss for them both these guys
Sexton a nice little one-legged fall
back haven't seen that before late
second quarter checker Wendy's game
summary con section
kicks it to the corner Taj the faith
about stolen good defense by the gold
Parker baccarat wheels right by time a
little too easy you're really going to
have to get closer to him you can't give
him the old type of open look beautiful
pea tears nice at the pocket Alex lamp
[Applause]